buongiorno studenti siamo qui riuniti
per fare sperimenta e stranamente totò
alcol negli span cut off e noci qui per
insegnare poi fare esperimenti e molto
molto pericolose questo canale che
secondo figlio anche bambini quindi
pappette oggi dottor con harris fan
cutoff insegne fuori a fare dentifricio
capelle fante cazzo sempre del tpc per
del famoso però lo facciamo seguire le
istruzioni da i presenti che sa fare
tutte tutte le cose perché studiate il
sacco di anni prima di cominciare enti
scrivere tutti quanti o catherine che
useremo in queste vite acque ossigenate
ha così gelate verde acque ossigenate
ros e questo non so che c'è dentro è
però è come ultima cosa molto importante
pacchetti news calmante bacchette di
musica manda serve per girare e dare
ingrediente segreto che baci e
cominciano prima cosa è venuta come si
chiamano solo ampolle prima cosa da fare
ragazzi e prendere però sitting sposare
questo è che non si vinca csen sennò
primo ingrediente di oggi ne è
ossigenata tutte questa bottiglietta was
quotate in questa folle quindi basso
tanto tempo
ban cominciano infatti è così difficile
germania a york perfetta secondo e
bottigliette di acqua ossigenata velo
molte poche molto poche
molte poche basta secondo ingrediente di
oggi sapone per acqua ossigenata il
verde hulk ossigenate burden che va
messa in tante più o meno io tor
io fare cose to see the bass va così da
tè verde accusi girate rose che serve
totò avere fatto male ad inserire ha
così cenate mosse mescolare tutte quante
prendiamo pacchetti td scdma under magie
basta mescolare
ancora non capisco questo ragazzi fine
piante per aiutare azione in punte
create dalla cassa in me cane
l'ingrediente segreto tutto quanto
funzione boccacce fa tutto schifo
tosto grazie così tanto tanto di nuovi
li mortacci sua ford ka venditrice
d'elefante è in fermento del sito e
portami uno straccio di previdenza tatò
e anche stare solidità di denti quei c'è
[Musica]
poi il podio solite dentifricio funzione
ben più contente di aver fatto questo
esperimento è da anni la mano e questa
cosa mi capisce mamma mamma mamma giuro
io lavorerò anche mare man mano giuro
bastano mai noci ma allora ci sono tutti
addosso tutta italia eccolo eccolo 4
vivo e smarrimento riuscite prime bene
per te
secondo estremamente stessa cosa però ha
così generato blu prendere nuova
boccette di ampolle ripetere spa
evidente con acqua ossigenata e tutte le
case da per me lo sapete prodiane dottor
entravo in questi esperimenti e ma
perché io studiate 12 anni nard
conosciuta more drame bitter fatto scala
in mente primo chiare rimaste singer
padre ha così gen ardenti the baster
sapone scusa al così giornate aperte
andrare di sapone e adesso tocco di
classe che sarebbe queste che dovrebbe
mettere tutto dentro
abbiamo 4 quarto mescolato e adesso
poteva fare secondo st rimettere secondo
esperimento l unica quanto al resto la
pole borja c'è qualche in quanto figlia
ma che schifo da hera perché siccome
abbiamo jasmine chiato tutta tutto
tavole già smettiamolo per bene
[ __ ] mamma ho bisogno di aiuto
porta in porta anche nonna oggi siamo
qui riuniti per testimoniare questa
incredibile esperimento insite in vita
mia non è mai uscito in casa è riuscito
a uscirne dopo la cosa che sporcato di
più nei uscita chissà perché mi piace di
poter perché deve sporcare tutto che
condividete con nemici e con la norma l
così lo fate anche voi
questa era la bacchetta di musca mander
quello digitale
spero che mi sia piaciuto ragazzi cosi
come non mi piace anche ai vari social
che come un invito a tornare per tiziana
servizi 16 mi chiamano prossimo video da
ragazzi si è aperto per terra e gli
occhi capelli non solo dove partire per
pulire aiuta più casa aggravate nella
notte